do you support theresa may at the end
there uh reluctantly standing up no
applause well we're going to speak to uh
conservatives backing each of the two
contenders uh this evening uh to start
with we're going to talk to you soon act
supporter and that is victoria
apprentice the environment minister uh
thank you so much for being uh with us
hello sophie you're gonna miss boris
johnson i saw you laughing along to that
and one time he was on form today he
really was um
he is a great performer in the commons
he's he's a great he's been a great
performer in the country too and i think
we will all remember him with um a
certain amount of affection
and i want to talk to you about uh rishi
sunak who of course you are backing it
feels like until now he's been the front
runner you know he's been comfortably
ahead with the mps but now of course it
goes to conservative party members and
it's a bit of a different story isn't it
according to all of the polling liz
trust is ahead when it comes to the
member's vote well the polling is i
think very difficult to read because of
course nobody knows who our members are
or where our members are so they're a
notoriously difficult bunch to identify
and then
manage to poll 800 of them it's quite
easy yes but that that's not really a
great poll size i i think i think it's
very hard to tell who's who starts
foremost in the members minds they've
got time to make up their minds
they're quite a sophisticated electorate
they've done this several times before
in recent years they've done it quite a
lot i'm meeting with my members in my
constituency tomorrow evening to chat
through the pluses and minuses of both
candidates and i suspect mps up and down
the country will be doing that at the
same time it feels like even rishi sunak
himself
admits that he's the underdog he said do
we start from behind yes we do we're in
a video released on twitter we certainly
did a few weeks ago i think it was not
envisaged that our campaign would have
gone as well as it has
so i i think rishi is right to recognize
that we've made real progress over the
last few weeks i think he's performed
very well
both in the private hustings that we've
had in parliament and we've had loads of
those and also in in the more public
telly hustings
so i think
so far my perspective is we're running a
good campaign
rishi's real values of decency honesty
hard work real ability and focus on the
evidence are coming through and i think
our members will notice that um it's
interesting isn't it the tone of the
leadership campaign you know we heard
kissed armor there just plucking at what
the candidates are saying about each
other and throwing them straight back at
boris johnson does the prime minister
agree with rishi sunak the plans put
forward by his rivals are nothing more
than the fantasy economics of unfunded
spending promises i mean it's not
helpful is it this kind of thing from
well i think we've always been a really
broad church in the conservative party
and i think growing up debate about
policy
is fine actually fantasy economics well
it's it was a debate and and rishi was
getting his point across
i think what has been less helpful is
the very
nasty sort of personal smearing that
that seems to have gone on but i i never
know how much of that is real and how
much is made up but i think what's very
important from our point of view is that
we are here to run a positive campaign
we're going to be telling
our voting public why rishi would make a
really good prime minister and all about
his good qualities and i think that's
the way to do it you say you want to run
a positive campaign uh rasheed simax
also tweeted to say today
in the video who is the best person to
beat kirstama and the labour party at
the next election i believe i am the
only candidate who can do that so do you
think liz trust could win an election i
think rishi
is the best candidate for winning an
election and that's why i'm backing him
of course he's the only candidate well
he's running for leader it's perfectly
proper for him to think and believe in
himself and i think that's the right way
to be i have a lot of respect for liz
too in fact i have a lot of respect to
all of those candidates that put
themselves forward for the leadership
it's a really brave thing to do and
golly politics is brutal i walked
through the lobby with penny mordant
almost immediately after
she she came third today and she was
there in public with all her colleagues
most of whom had voted for other people
and it it's a it's a funny old world
yeah it certainly is uh you know it does
feel like it's moving at breakneck speed
at the minute
uh as well and i've been doing some
interviews as well with people earlier
and two other people who backed uh rishi
sunik were talking about liz truss's
policy agenda she said she wants a bold
new economic policy and both liam fox
and mark harper said to me that look if
she strays too far from the 2019
manifesto that of course you were
elected on then maybe it's right start
looking at a new mandate i.e another
election i'm really not keen on having
another election i think it's very
important that we have a period of
stability and calm now we've had a heck
of a time since the 2019 election we've
obviously had the coven pandemic we've
got war in europe now we are now facing
some really big challenges in my own
brief with cost of living and the cost
of food for example we got news on
inflation today
i really want a period of calm quiet
careful evidence-led government delivery
focused just making sure that we we get
our policies out there we we perform in
a way that people need us to do and we
give people help where they need us so
not strained too far from the last
manifesto well we were elected on a
manifesto we haven't really had much of
a chance to put many of those policies
into action because of the pandemic and
then the war so it is really important i
think that we come back together as a
party and i felt that today in pmqs i
felt as we said goodbye to boris in the
chamber i felt real unity and
and sort of a sense of purpose back in
the party
almost when we won that election and we
were elected on that manifesto so i
think it's important
that we do
get on with the business of governing
okay and thank you very much indeed
victoria apprentice